and how beloved he is not only across
the league here in the States but all
over the globe as well fun matchup first
time these two match up together Zion
little putback turned in too quickly and
those Dylan OVA products even chins oh
and Josh Hart such key figures for their
teams as Yonex scores inside for the
Bucks Karl Malone came in the league he
was sub 70 in the 60s maybe in the 50s
and he improved Zion take it on the
Greek Creek and the honest meets him at
the rim the understand the possession of
New Orleans and this is where the height
and length of the honest pulled one out
but Zion right here yes it was contact
but that's when you used that right hand
he put didn't get a chance to benefit in
LA once LeBron came into the fold
Ghana scores on Zion is hard on the push
ball in the corner and ball up misses
the three and Sion takes it away from
the honest and a foul and if that's all
the honest all this in the summer league
in preseason where
[Applause]
Williamson just the vice grips to
basketball and takes it away